好 欢迎回来 赵华
阿倫说
我们赶快来欢迎第二位来宾
刚刚已经讲了产业面
是
接下来就要看所谓的量价关系了
跟着怎么样 越线没量
越线没量
没关系
朱老师来就有量
先来欢迎他
就是我们的朱嘉宏老师
K仙之身
大家好
跟我们太熟了
对
对 常常碰面
因为最近朱老师
有帮盘下了一个注解
好事总是多磨
对
因为盘好磨
沒錯 沒錯
最近盤大家覺得很難做
但是什麼事情都有這個
好事多磨嘛
那就後面有好事
所以現在在磨磨你
對 但是不管
我們在這個中間很難做
但是你一定會有收穫的
那投資也是一樣
我們投資也是有賺有賠
但是你在賺賠的中間
你也會有很多寶貴的經驗
然後奠定你日後成功
所以你经过一段磨练
那以后大机会来
那你就是你的
因为大家可能被前一阵子
那种大的波动养坏胃口了
其实股市的盘整是常态
对
所以从盘整中找机会是更重要的
没错
主要是最近我们一直在讲
就是量的问题
因为好的时候有到1兆
就1.8兆
对
现在的话五六千亿
差这么多
所以量价关系要教我们来看
股價的推背圖
其實在股市裡面
你如果看懂量價關係
你都知道它後面的變化
但是一般人
為什麼不太容易分辨
就是你把量價關係
跟趨勢分開來
你只看量
實際上我們看量價關係
要跟趨勢結合
你是在看多頭空頭
還是現在在盤整
盤整裡面也會有量
有的時候有量收
有時候量增
好 像多頭趨勢這邊有講
多頭起漲
量增就一漲
那我们大部分都做多
所以如果你是在起涨
也就是我们讲到回后埋上涨
盘整突破
这都是第一根
如果第一根有量的话
那这个我们一般来说
它就容易涨
也叫做供给量
这个量叫供给量
多头行进中的话
量增就会续涨
对 那如果一样
它行进的意思就是
第二天第三天
连续再放量
那当然他就是继续在供企
那如果多头遇到高档量增就不好了
那高档我们就讲过三天以上
第三天第四天
这个地方如果继续的放大量的话
那你就要小心了
因为在高档有量容易被人家出货
因为量说他们没办法出货
但量一大就容易出货
那怎么观察呢
就是如果他有大量
第二天股价不涨了
或者当天
当天放了大量
结果开高走低
股价下跌
那这时候大概出货的几率就非常高
你要小心
那同样的一样上涨到高档预压了
预压力的一样
所以量增也是同样是出货的概念了
因为你预压本来就是有人在解套
到了这些位置了
你就要注意
这个地方可能是出货
那换句话讲
第一个我们做多不会买在高档
也不会买在压力
可是你手上有多单
这时候你要准备停利
要停利
最后当然是刚刚讲到
这些可能都造成回档
可是回档只要量开始缩了
那就代表卖压减少了
因为多头回档
在高档爆量就是该出的就出了
或截套的有卖掉了
那你这时候就要看回来
如果回来量缩掉
这个量缩反而好
表示卖压减轻
也没有很大的继续在杀你
那如果量缩的话
碰到支撑的就容易停住了
因为我们支撑就是一个对抗下跌
那你下跌量少
我支撑够强
我自然就会把它抵住
那点住的时候
我们就会看到
它会不会又出现第一个量增上涨
对不对
因为你量缩
然后我把你撑住
你再出来一个量增的上涨
那它又开始供下面一波
好 一个循环
好 这在多头里面
大概你的位置都有了
多頭上漲 高檔 預壓 回檔預支撐大概你把這些量放上去你做多大概可以研判那在空投裡面就不一樣了空投裡面各位就不要看錯了
比如說空投起跌
就低跟下跌
低跟下跌如果有大量
那就不但會跌還容易急跌
可能連續就殺下去了
所以在空投的起跌地方
是我們做空
那做空有量就變好了
它会大跌嘛
所以就可以继续空它这样
那行径如果量缩
大家容易误会
这跟刚才不一样
刚才说下跌量缩好
对不对
这边讲的
可是空头下跌量缩
还会继续跌
因为各位有一个观念
我空头下跌
是不是要涨的话
要有人来买
要有人接
对
那如果你是量缩
表示你不要乱接
很多人都看价钱去接股票
哇 跌三天了
人家摸底
那結果它沒有量
我們一般閃貨去摸
你摸不出來的
一定要有別人來大量
所以量說會續跌
那空投低檔就是跌了兩三天
也就是這個的相反
跌了兩三天
量放大了
它反而容易止住
就是有點底部放大量
對 底部放量
然後有人來買了
這個時候容易反彈
容易反彈我們要確認
那就是第二天
我如果底部放量第二天不跌了
或者下引线或者变反
这个地方大概就容易反弹
那容易反弹对我们来讲
因为我们做多嘛
空头你不能做多
反弹不能做多
所以这是给你空单要回补的
如果你是做空单在低档
也看到大量
那你就准备回补了
要回补了
那如果你下跌遇到了支撑
空头我们现在都在讲空头
不是多头遇到支撑
空头如果遇到
比如说你跌跌跌到半年线
那这个地方如果出现有量大
它一样也容易反弹
这个地方有支撑
就有支撑的力量出现
那另外空头上涨
那叫反弹
所以这个都要搞
空头反弹
如果量缩
它就容易结束
也就是说我们反弹无量
反弹无力
反弹无量就准备做空
准备
也许它谈不动
明天就跌了
那明天一跌又回来这里了
又变起跌
我们多空都有讲
所以多空不但有讲
而且多空的每个位置
你都可以去配合再看一下
你今天看到大量
是多头的这里了
还是空头的这里
那我相信你对这个量
就能够分析了
那还有一个盘整
大家比较忽略盘整
盘整里面有两种情形
在多头的盘整
如果这个多头要攻的话
大概量都会缩
在盘整里面不太会有量
那在什么时候才有量
就是盘整的突破
也就是我们多头的起涨
盘整的突破
那这个时候就会有量
那另外一个就是盘整放量
在多头也会盘整里面放量
那这要小心 要看位置
如果你这个盘整在第三波
末升段
那有可能会做头
所以不能跌破
如果盘整放量的跌破
那个量就是主力出货
就主力出货
那空头呢
如果是跌到低档了
空头一直跌跌到低档
那也在盘整吧
这个地方如果放量的话
那就是我们刚刚讲
空头放量就会反弹
那这个地方放量
盘整如果是突破
它就转多了
那这个量就叫
我们就叫做进货量
主力在这边进货
所以你如果是盘整
也是看多头的盘整
还是空头的盘整
还是多头底部的盘整
还是空头底部的盘整
还是多头高档的盘整
你加上量价
最后看它是突破还是跌破
你大概也知道
这个成交量代表什么意思
是 我们现在的台股位置
算是多头高档的盘整吗
对 因为现在跌破前提
所以是盘整
那现在盘整量输
对
原来是好事
我们讲了那么大一篇
现在是好事
對啊
所以我們現在大盤
趨勢改的嘛可是量縮啦量縮就等著量增等著大量來把這個盤整突破它就會有走另外一波
我們每次卡在你們兩個中間
你們兩個都了然於胸
然後我就在旁邊很吃驚這樣子
對
不會啊
那你就代表觀眾
今天不可以考試囉
今天沒有時間考試
我們就看看範益就知道了
有些股票前面都走過了
但是你当时可能不知道量价的关系
那现在知道你可以回头看一下
好
你就会发现真的有道理
你看这一波一路下跌对不对
量缩 这边没有量
还会跌
你不要以为量缩你随便就去减
你减了它还会跌
那什么时候才不会跌这里
下跌低档 低档大量
它就容易停了
那容易停还要看第二天
第二天涨停板
那这一涨停板当然没有量
这个没话讲
因为开盘就涨停了
那涨停板本身也代表很多的
背后的意义
这个也是阻力开的
然后第二天就看到了有量了
开始连续放量
所以这个叫大量反弹
那反弹我们都好高兴
你可能去追高什么
不要忘了这才高档
反弹但高档不要谁放
放量
你如果放量大
它就容易回来
好 那這一回來
這個大量就變成壓力了
所以你在這個地方
遇到壓力的大量
千萬不要追好
千萬不要追了
對 你在壓力的大量
你一去追它就回來了
所以現在
假設以這檔滑爆電量來講
因為高檔爆量
高檔爆量
而且跌破了
對
那就是我們講盤整有量
跌破了
所以它變空頭了
是
所以現在也一樣
就算你連漲三天
你都不能卖
因为这个是阻力
我们也不一定是阻力
在这个地方就有大量的卖压在这
那这也有可能上次跌
上次大跌很多人
你看最高点是不是大量
所以那边有被套牢
所以你在这个急速反弹的时候
这里就有一些卖压在这
这样子我们去观察
把趋势看好现在是空头
所以空头如果反弹没量
它不会上的
它不会上去的
刚刚那个表各位回去看一下
空头反弹煤量是要做空的
是 就弹不动了
再下来要做空
所以这样子大家就可以配合上来
好 金居
好 那金居也一样
涨到700多块 创历史高点
然后这里面出了两个大量
那这两个大量如果跌破
这个是空头嘛 对不对
反弹又下来
那这个就是我们刚刚讲的
多头的高档
金居涨到700多是高高在上
那在你的大量盘整不可以跌破
那跌破是出貨
所以这是主力在出货
主力出掉
那出掉了空头下跌量是缩的
这没有量
那可是还会跌
一路跌
那什么时候你才会觉得有机会
就是沙沙沙出现大量
那大量第二天也是涨停板
然后来开始反弹
从这个反弹才会打出底底高
然后变成多头
那多头这里有大量
为什么因为这里有压
这里有个季线
季线压在上面
所以在这里有了大量
可是这个大量
它已经变成一个多头架构
现在已经你的量价
要换成多头的那一块了
前面这是空头这一块
现在变成多头来看量
好 那我们现在的趋势
我们的经驱在盘整
很清楚嘛 头头低
但有没有破底 还没有
所以它是一个盘整
那在多头里面
这已经是多头的盘整
那多头盘整这里有大量
这里有大量
所以这个盘整不可以跌破
那跌破就是这个多又转空
那如果突破呢
那突破就很好了
多头盘整如果大量突破
它就再回去攻那个七八
七五八
要再回去攻七五八
所以这里就变成量价很关系的位置
你是往上凸了还是往下跌破
因为你跌破这里有大量被套牢了那这个有可能短期因为我们在低档是不是有大量那可能短期這些進貨的在這裡你就先走掉了所以這個後面大家要密切去看一下
那我們就來檢驗一下最近的熱門題材股
最近有緊支股票
郁金光回檔減少停辦
郁金光非常強
可是我們有沒有看到
它這裡有個大量
這邊
對 這個在高檔
所以它會整理會休息
会休息
那休息以后
它再冲出去的时候没有量
那没有量就容易回来
我们讲上涨要有量
所以其实上它这一根
这根回后买上涨盘整突破
它没有量
所以它很容易回来
那回来以后
它现在又开始放量
下跌的时候有量
这有量
但是它碰到支撑了
那这个应该是今天
今天所长听
对
那今天就是遇到支撑
然后出现
但今天有一个弱点就是没有量
因为他锁住了
那怎么办
锁住了 因为太好了
好 没关系
没有量就看明天
因为我们量是可以延续看
如果我起涨第一天量不够
就要看后面来补量
因为你要攻上面高点
就可以补量
第一个要确认趋势
它以现在来讲趋势并不好
它是盘整
因为它把这个低点跌破了
它前面这个低点跌破了
所以它是过高破低
过高破低
你的压力就在1140
那你1140的压力
你这边的量不太够
所以要持续放量
去过这个1140
它才会多头延续
那这日股股票是底部
滑金因为最近资安很热
因为这个很明确
因为它多头确认了
那1234
所以在高档
然后又在压力
对不对
所以它是多头高档
预压的爆量
所以明后天不能跌
只能涨不能跌
因为你有大量
这个量超级大
涨的话就是换手成功
那跌的话就是
预压爆量这个短线获利
短线获利一层两层
有可能这边卖压就出来
所以如果这只手上有多单的
你已经预压爆量
所以要注意
股價只能漲不能跌
明天要收黑K
大家要回檔
那你就可以短線獲利一趟
就可以獲利一趟
那回檔再看嘛
量縮嘛
那就是良性的價量配合
那這個我們都可以去追蹤
好 最後看一下
被動元件的合升堂
合升堂跟我們剛才講的
價量關係一樣
這邊有大量做反彈
反彈的最高點
這裡連續三天大量
这三天都大量
那大量这里就产生了压力
所以一样你把这个压力画一条线
OK
那如果在
因为为什么这边还会整理一下
因为这时候季线还没有做好
月线还在下面
那现在整理大家也发现月线已经
开始要过季线
那现在只欠一个东风
因为这里全部都有大量
对不对
那如果这个红K一过来
那这个大量就是底部量
它就是空头低档盘整的大量
那这个大量突破
那当然一定是供那个1045
因为这个量绝对够去供这个地方
那个是高档的量
然后被跌破了
所以那边有人被套牢
现在是低档盘整的量
那突破它就去挑战那名
那这样大家可以去追踪一下
好 子倩东风你喊一下啊
好 东风
东风快来啊
会啦 因为大盘如果整理好
大盘转向
自然有资金的人
一定都是看这种底部打底的股票
是
那如果你又突破
那个资金就会进来了
好 今天非常谢谢朱老师
其实量价关系很值得研究
就像大家可能觉得最近闷盘
还有人说最近就是交易的垃圾时间
可是其实呼应到盘面的局势是好的
因為盤整量所等突破
一旦突破後面真的就是很值得期待
所以你看懂了你就很幽呆的等
很幽默
你不會擔心
可以不要上班嗎